- Welcome, everyone
it's to the first seminar
for the spring 2021,
so we have the pleasure of
having Thomas Ginn today
from the Center for Global Development
and he will be presenting the paper
on "Prisoner or Sanctuary?
An Evaluation of Camps
for Syrian Refugees".
So Thomas, he's a part of
the migration, displacement
and humanitarian policy team at the CGD
and his current research
ask how to design policy
and allocate the assistance
to benefit refugees
and host communities alike.
His research of the Middle
East examines the trade-off
of camps and opening schools to refugees.
And in randomized controlled
trials in East Africa
he studying how livelihoods
programs can improve
both economic outcomes
and social cohesion.
As a principal investigator
of the "Let Them Work" initiative,
he's studying how refugees
labor market access
affect host communities attitudes
and levels of humanitarian assistance.
Prior to joining a CGD, Dr.
Ginn worked at the World Bank
on a survey of Syrian refugees in Lebanon,
Jordan and Iraqi Kurdistan
and with the Innovation for
Poverty Action in Kenya.
He received his PhD in economics
from Stanford University
and his bachelors degree
from the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill.
So just before passing to him,
let me just remind you
that we are recording
as you are aware this seminar,
if you have declined to
accept the Yale policy
on recording material, please make sure
that you have your camera turned off
and you cannot ask questions live
but if you, if you send
them through the "Chat"
we'll make sure to, to ask them.
So there you go, so Thomas please.
- Great, Teresa, thank you so much,
thank you to you, to Tarana,
to Mushfiq for inviting me
and for organizing this
and thank you to everyone
for coming today,
I'm excited to be here.
So before I get started,
you please interrupt me
with questions at any time.
So we can just do this like econ seminar,
just to interrupt me
whenever questions come up
or to put them in the "Chat".
Great, so my name is Thomas
Ginn, I'm a research fellow
at the Center for Global Development
and I'll be talking today about
"Camps for Syrian Refugees".
As I'm sure this audience is, is aware
about 80 million people are
displaced by conflict worldwide
and at least 10 million
of these displaced people,
live in official camps or settlements
that are managed by usually the UN.
So the alternative that
I want you to think about
in this talk, is that
otherwise displaced people,
they're still displaced but
they live in towns, cities,
informal settlements, they self settle
and have to find their own, find and pay
for their own accommodation
and consistent with the
humanitarian dialogue,
I'm gonna call all of these people urban
even though a few of
them live in rural areas.
So some of the reasons
that that camps exist,
oftentimes these are negotiations
between the host governments
and the international community,
the main argument being
that host governments
want to isolate refugees
in order to minimize crowd out
in terms of the labor market,
in terms of public services,
in terms of the housing market
and so as a way to, to
keep refugees isolated
from the host communities.
The nonprofits, humanitarians
also find this efficient
to identify and to distribute
the most vulnerable
for short-run assistance.
But critics of camps rightly note
that it's, makes it much easier
to impose serious restrictions
on movements violating the
convention for refugees
and human rights, for, for
refugees who are in camp
and also as displacement
is such a long-run event,
in many cases, the worry
is that camps will prevent
long-run self-reliance
for refugees who are in camps.
So given these criticisms, in 2014
the UN High Commissioner
for Refugees, UNHCR,
announced a policy change
that camps would now be the exception,
only a temporary measure after a history
of only kind of serving
refugees who were in camps.
This is the question
that I wanna look at here
is, to think about what are the effects
of creating a camp on well-being.
And I'm gonna talk mostly today
about the effects on camp residents
because I think
that's where we have the
least amount of data for now
but I'm also gonna then extend this
and think about the
effects of creating a camp
on urban refugees and on
host citizens at the end.
There we go.
So the setting that I'm gonna look at
is the largest displacement setting
in the world right now, that's Syrians,
I'm gonna be looking at mostly
Syrian refugees in Jordan
and in Northern region of
Iraq, the Kurdistan region
and so here we're looking
at the Za'atari Camp,
a population of about 80,000
people in Northern Jordan
and to illustrate some of the
criticisms from, of camps,
the Affordable Housing
Institute's 2014 report starts out
that if the road to hell is
paved with good intentions,
then the newest slum, Za'atari in Jordan,
is a four-lane highway there.
And so, I went into this project
expecting to find negative effects.
I thought it was important
to add measurement to this,
this policy discussion
with new data that I helped to collect
and I've spent time in these camps
and it's obvious that life
is very difficult and boring.
But when I studied the data,
it's also, it's not
easy to form perceptions
on the alternative
because most urban refugees
are less visible to nonprofits
and to journalists and I
think we want to assume
that they're doing better
and I think that's where
rigorous data collection
is so important and in
this case, kind of led
to some surprising findings for me.
So the research questions
that I'm interested in here,
how does living in a camp
instead of the local community,
affect a variety of outcomes
and I'm gonna start out
with labor market, labor market outcomes,
like wages and employment
and then crucially look at this income
relative to the cost of living.
So refugees in camps don't pay any rent
and that's gonna become an
important part of my story here.
Then of course, I'm gonna
look at all the other factors
that we have data on
that, that inform places
about how satisfied we are
with the places we live,
things about access to
education, to healthcare,
your social networks,
perceptions of safety
and then the respondents were asked
about an overall measure of satisfaction
to kind of weight these
criteria as they see fit.
Then we wanna look at
how does this difference
across locations evolve over time.
So in this case, refugees
have been displaced
when we collected these data,
for on average of about three years,
so that's not speaking
to the long-run effects
that we're most concerned about
but at least gives us some extent
and I'll try to bolster this
with a few more recent surveys
of my findings here.
Then another kind of big
picture way to look at this
and I'm trying to think
about whether camps are cost-effective.
So would camp residents prefer
the additional aid expenses,
if camps were more expensive,
would they prefer that
additional aid in cash?
And whether camps in Jordan
are generating what economists
call a dead weight loss
or a potential efficiency
gain by these humanitarians
from opening.
The data that I'm gonna use,
we collected in 2015 and 2016
across Lebanon, the Iraqi
Kurdistan region in Northern Iraq
and in Northern Jordan.
And I'm gonna present the
estimates from Jordan first
because I have cost estimates
from both the government and
humanitarian organizations
on how much they're spending on refugees.
Dis-aggregated by location, in order
to kinda complete the picture
around cost-effectiveness,
there's also a larger literature
on the effects of urban
refugees on Jordanians,
so in order to contribute
to that discussion,
I'm also going to, to start with Jordan.
Just to give a very brief
setting of the context,
so 18% of refugees here are choosing
and I intentionally put
that in quotation marks
because some are, have more of a choice
than others for sure,
given the restrictions
and how they've evolved to live in camps.
And it's important also to note here
that contrary to many, many
other settings that direct aid
in Jordan was similar for
urban and camp refugees.
So that's gonna be one setting
that I'm gonna find these initial results
and I'm gonna extend to Iraqi Kurdistan
where there's a different
paradigm for hosting refugees
and see if the results hold there
and the story is, is remarkably similar.
And so these data we collected in 2016
and we asked people to recall
their outcomes from 2010
before the conflict and 2013
wherever they were at the time.
So in order to think about
whether camp refugees are similar
to other camp refugees and
control for those differences,
I'm first gonna take this
rich set of baseline variables
that we have from 2010
and do everything I can
to flexibly control for these
to find out kind of the most
comparable group to refugees
in camp settings, relative to counterparts
in urban settings, in
both Jordan and Kurdistan.
The second strategy I'm gonna use
that I'm not gonna talk
very much about today,
I can if you're interested
but I'm just going to illustrate it here
and it gives kind of similar results.
So I'm gonna use the
multinational nature of the survey
and compare refugees in Jordan
with refugees in Lebanon,
where for political economy reasons,
Lebanon never opened camps.
And so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna take,
so the first strategy is
going to compare refugees
who are, they moved from
Syria to Jordan here
and think about different
types of refugees,
some who went to camps and
some who went to the towns
in Jordan and then I'm gonna match them
based on their 2010
characteristics to refugees
because Lebanon was closer,
who went there instead.
And so I'm going to look at the difference
between refugees who
are in camps in Jordan,
relative to their matched
baseline counterparts,
who went to Lebanon instead
and look at this difference in outcomes
but of course the differences,
there's cross-country
differences in Lebanon overall
and so in order to net them
out, I'm then going to control
for the differences based on refugees
who I predict would have
gone to urban areas,
had they gone to Jordan.
So controlling for these
cross-country differences,
trying to again, estimate the differences
and the effect of living in a camp.
So that's gonna exploit
different variations,
require different assumptions
and give me very similar estimates
that I'm going to use to
kind of bolster my confidence
that the story that I'm telling
is real in this setting.
- Hey Thomas, before we move on
I've actually gotten confused
about what you're doing
and this is the, and
maybe this is the problem
with the interdisciplinary audience
where sometimes I imagine
the picture might be helpful
for a lot of people
and for me, like an equation,
might've been more helpful.
So could you, could you
just help us understand?
Okay, or maybe say it in different words
like in the form of estimating equations,
what the kind of that actually is?
- So the main strategy that
I'm talking about today,
is going to be controlling
for selection on observables
and then talking about what
the unobservable selection
might have been, looking
only within Jordan,
comparing refugees who are in camps
to refugees who are outside of camps.
Then I've got this second strategy
that exploits different
variation of refugees
who went to Lebanon and
we have this baseline,
baseline characteristics.
And so I'm then going to match them
based on their characteristics
before they were displaced
and look at this difference
in differences across Lebanon
and Jordan, based on whether I predict
they would go to camps
and then look at that
difference in difference
by whether they're
actually in camps or not,
to estimate a treatment
effect of being in camps.
- Okay, actually that helps a lot, thanks
and so when you say, "I'm
looking at a second strategy",
it's not a second separate strategy,
you are combining the two
to create the difference in difference?
- Well, so there are two
different strategies.
The results that I'm gonna
present mostly today,
are going to just be the, within Jordan...
- Within Jordan, okay.
- Yep, sort of...
- Sorry, Thomas, I have
a follow-up question
in addition to what Mushfiq asked,
now I'm interested to know that 18%
that you told us choose
between living in camps or not,
where do they come from,
in this difference in difference approach,
where is that 18%?
- So that's gonna be, the first
difference in that approach,
is going to be kind of
in, living in camps,
living outside of camps in Jordan...
- In Jordan.
- And the 100% in Lebanon
are living...
- Okay, got it.
- Awesome.
- And then, Thomas, you used the...
sometimes you were saying
controlling for observables,
sometimes you were saying matching,
so which of the two are you
doing like flexible controls
or observables or are you actually doing
some kind of form of matching process?
- Yeah, so the matching that I'm using,
I'm creating a propensity score
based on their observable characteristics
and then matching on
that propensity score.
- Okay, got it.
- So what do I, so what, what do I find
in top level results here?
The, I'm, consistent with a
lot of the criticism of camps,
I'm gonna find the camp
residence reduces income
and in order to standardize this,
I'm going to put this in a
per capita terms per month.
So the wage penalty for
living in a camp per person,
I'm estimating at $11 per person per month
but the crucial story here
is that they save $22 per
person per month for rent
and so that's a net at this stage
of $11 per person per
month, then I'm gonna look
at these other effects,
these other amenities
and find actually minimal
differences at this stage
between camp and urban residents,
then I'm gonna estimate
that services and aid are
more expensive in camps
by about $9 per person per month,
although this estimate is quite rough
but if you sum all this up,
that's gonna be a net
efficiency gain from camps
of about $2 per person
per month, very roughly.
Then if we think about a wider
picture here, urban refugees,
the main effect that falls
out from the other literature
around urban refugees in Jordan
is that the rent has increased
substantially for Jordanians.
We don't see much of an
effect on wages or on income,
we don't see much of
an effect on crowd out
from public services but a
massive increase in rent.
And so
the background here to what
I'm gonna be (mumbles),
so after four years, think
about overall camps in Jordan
are efficiently subsidizing refugees,
who again in quotes, kind of opt out
of the urban housing market
and thinking about camps
as bringing additional housing
at a time when both refugees
and the host communities
very much need that.
So I wanna pause here and say
that I'm not kind of saying
that camps by any stretch
of the imagination
are good places to live,
most definitely not,
that's not at all my argument
but I think what's important here
is that it actually may be
a much more depressing story
in that the life outside of camps
may be just as difficult for refugees
and so that just when we're
thinking about this potential,
it's just important to keep in mind.
- Thomas, I have a couple of
clarification questions here,
so the first is when you say
camp residence reduces income
or rent, et cetera, so
that's all relative to...
if you could keep it on that
slide that would be helpful.
That's all relative to a Syrian refugee
who happens to be located
outside of camp, correct?
- Yep.
- And then when you have
the $9 per person per month
in services and aid, that's
including the housing,
like that's what we should
be comparing directly
to the rent number that
you have right above it?
- The service and aid
number, that's everything
the government and that
nonprofits put in externally.
- Okay,
but then, I mean, that may
not be the total social cost
of housing somebody in a camp.
Not, it's not just the external funds
but if it's like, the government
is providing some space
which has some opportunity costs
but that's not being valued in here?
- At this point, exactly.
So in, in Jordan, these were,
this was just empty desert
that yes, you're exactly
right, it's not valued in...
- When you say empty desert,
you just mean to imply
that that had very low opportunity cost?
- Indeed, yep.
- And so...
- And you're right,
that's not valued in here.
- Okay, so now then the question becomes,
like something we should be grappling with
is like the empty desert,
like there may be unobserved differences
in the quality of that location,
like how pleasant it is to
live in the empty desert
that's far away from other
amenities, et cetera,
that's probably welfare relevant
but we probably don't have
that being counted in the 22
versus a nine.
- For sure, yeah.
- Okay, so 22 might be, there's nothing,
there's nothing here that suggests
that's like meant to imply
that, Oh, camps are magically
like creating some efficiency
gain by, by the government,
like building a lot of housing together
that in a decentralized way,
the private sector could not provide,
it could be that this, this
reflects all the differences
but it could also be that,
Oh yeah, by building a camp,
that's huge economies of scale
and that's how we're
generating some efficiency.
- Exactly, I'm gonna
talk about that actually
in a couple slides from now
but yes, I'm talking about camps
as a potential coordinating device
around like what, with a large
group of people coming in,
so yes, that's one way to think about it,
to follow up on that,
so one of the camps is about 20 minutes
from the next largest city,
so when you think about kind
of environmental differences,
it's outside of the kind of urban area
but not that far outside
and another one is much further away.
But also then that's another reason
I like the estimate of satisfaction
that respondents can place in something
like the heat of living in a desert
without any vegetation
around and things like that.
So, but yes, I totally agree.
The question about how water trucking in
and waste trucking out that
is included in these service,
the service costs, these
costs are from 2014
and I just, I'll talk more about this
but those costs have gone down
as the Jordanian government
has allowed more kind of
permanent ish infrastructure
to be constructed but that is...
- Thomas also, for example, when you say
about urban amenities what are you saying
in terms of schools and all that,
is that also measured or...?
- Yes, exactly, so these costs include
all kinds of healthcare, education, food
and gas subsidies are
a huge cost in Jordan
as well as electricity and
all of that is priced in
to the kind of additional costs
that refugees are imposing
on either the government or on donors.
So it's a very rough estimate
but it's, it's attempted at
least to be taken into account.
- Hi, Thomas, can I interrupt
for one second quickly?
Sorry, do you hear me well?
Actually I'm calling from
Lebanon so, and my, my PhD
is about refugees in Lebanon.
So just to clarify, maybe
probably you're doing it later on,
are you taking this as a
benchmark to compare these figures
with same figures for
Syrian refugees in Lebanon?
- So that's what I do
in the second strategy
that I won't, but I can, I
can talk more about but...
- I just wanted to clarify quickly
because Syrian refugees in Lebanon,
we don't have camps here (mumbles)
and they actually do pay rent.
So I just wanna see if you're
factoring this later on.
- Exactly, and that's I think
a relevant counterfactual
because these refugees didn't have
kind of there weren't any camps
in order to, to move into,
so it's a very rough, natural experiment
how they exactly...
- Okay, I'll wait, I'll wait.
Sorry, thanks.
- No, thank you.
Great, okay, and then
so just a brief overview
of the literature, this is part of a...
There was a report in the World Bank
that summarized these data
but it was never made public
and we're kind of seeing a
growing collection of data
of an outcomes for displaced
including work by Mushfiq
Mobarak for the Rohingya
but I think, so one thing I'm doing here
is this is extensive
data bringing in attempts
of kind of identification
question around this question
that hasn't been, been discussed much
and cost-effectiveness.
Then zooming back a little
bit, the economics is talking
more about kinda place-specific effects,
so whether that's immigrant enclaves
or in general neighborhood effects
and I think it's important
here to think about this
in terms of humanitarian context
and a place that is actually
created that the social planner
has a choice of whether to create or not.
So I'm gonna then jump
into kind of framework
that I mentioned to Mushfiq
and then the setting data,
down to the results
and then conclude with
a policy discussion.
So when you think about
kind of a big picture
of how people are allocated across space
and urban economists
are thinking about this
in terms of the returns to scale
in that you get from positive
kind of agglomeration
in, versus congestion costs
if you think about traffic
but especially rent.
And so if we think about kind
of there's one existing city
and a wave of forced migrants arrive,
if we just kind of let
the market allocate this
on kind of the margin,
then households can choose
either the city or the desert
based on their own kind of private returns
and their, they kind of feel benefit
to always kind of locating in the city.
But at some point there might
be more negative externalities
for the marginal person coming in,
than the, than the positive social costs.
And so if we think
about then they would allocate
themselves all into one city
and this total welfare would be positive
but would eventually start to decline
as urban economists have noted
that some cities seem to be like too large
relative to the, the costs and benefits.
If we think about a
social planner instead,
that they could choose these city sizes
based on the total social
welfare, you could have,
you could divide this group into two
and doubled the social benefit
where, where it's positive
and at some point with a
large enough population,
you have the total social
welfare exceeds, with two cities,
exceeds the kind of like
marginal everyone deciding this
for themselves of, of one city.
And so one potential
way to think about this
is camps is acting as a
coordinating mechanism
for new, new arrivals
to, to locate around.
So I think many people are
familiar with the context,
Syria it's more than
half a million are killed
at this point, the
conflict started in 2011
and now the largest
host country is Turkey,
which we don't have any data for,
the second largest host
country is, is Lebanon,
I'm gonna focus mostly on Jordan,
where there's about 600,000 refugees
and then talk a little bit about Iraq,
where there's 250,000 mostly
Syrian, Kurdish refugees,
as well as data that we have
on internally displaced people
who came from Southern Iraq
into the Kurdistan region.
In Jordan at this point,
about one in 14 people is a Syrian refugee
and that was the second
highest total globally
at that point,
at this point again, they do not,
refugees do not have access
to the formal labor market.
So if you're following the
Jordan compact discussion,
this changed shortly after the survey
but it's important to keep in context,
the institutions at the time,
which refugees did not have any access
to the formal labor market.
As I said before, refugees
are getting direct assistance,
both camp and urban residents
in terms of food factors,
in-kind or in terms of cash
and I have data on all of that.
They're supposed to be
getting free education
and some free healthcare
and for the most part,
that's happening in the data
although expenses are slightly
higher outside of camps
and then the other comparison
between limitations on movement
is that camp residents,
they, there's limitations in both.
Camp residents need a
permit to leave temporarily
and so their freedom of movement
is most definitely restricted.
But urban residents in this
context also significantly worry
about arrests over having
the right paperwork
and also expressed
limitations on their movement
in just different ways.
So in Jordan, there's two main camps.
This is Za'atari, the
largest one of 80,000 people,
Azraq is the second one with 30,000 people
and I'll talk more about
the comparisons at the end,
these are the populations in 2016
and it's basically stayed
that way to the present day.
Za'atari was opened in
2012 and at that point,
the Jordanian government
required residents upon arrival
but this became just very unsustainable,
given the infrastructure at the time,
about 200,000 refugees are estimated
to have been in the camps at some point
and moved to urban areas
through either formal means,
there was a bailout policy or an informal,
just leaving in the middle of the night,
that was a major story kind of going on
and responsible for a lot of
the sorting early the crisis.
62% of employment in the camps
is going to be through nonprofits.
So this is gonna be an
important thing to keep in mind,
we're talking about income for
refugees especially in camps
and 80% of employment
is, is inside the camps.
But I think about this
employment through nonprofits
as comparable in many
ways to public services.
So these, they're providing some,
all kinds of different services
that nonprofits are providing
and when we think about 50%
almost of the Jordanian population
is working in the public
sector, in some ways,
those are analogous for
the refugee population.
The other thing to keep in
mind here is that at this time,
Jordan was imposing "Nothing
permanent" restrictions
on the camps, so they
couldn't build with concrete,
they couldn't really invest
in the things like water,
infrastructure, waste management
that was mentioned earlier.
And so these are kind of like lower bounds
for what a camp could be
if there was more openness
to making these a longer term investment.
The data that I'm gonna use,
I collected in partnership
with the World Bank, UNHCR
and the Danish aid organizations, Danida,
in the first stage we
randomly selected areas
and then stratified by
the percentage of Syrians
and then in the second stage,
we randomly selected households
and then selected a mix
of hosts and Syrians
in each one of these small neighborhoods.
This is mostly going to be
representative for Jordan,
it's not quite representative,
it's only in certain governorates
and there was an additional
sample that we surveyed
in order to bolster
the, the sample in Amman
but it's going to include
unregistered refugees
and I'm mostly gonna be
using the sampling weights
that we, that we calculated.
We had a response rate above 85%,
so I think we have most,
mostly attrition is not much of a worry,
I think we can call these
mostly representative
and it's consistent with other surveys
that have been done in Jordan as well.
I'm gonna talk about some market migration
and attitude questions as well
and this was done through, we
sampled two 15 to 64-year-olds
randomly in each household
and so it's not the whole
household that we have that for.
And as before I said
that we have, the survey was done in 2016
and I'm gonna have outcomes,
we asked them to recall
from September, 2010
before the conflict and September, 2013.
So first look at these data here.
Again, as we kind of
said and as consistent
with a lot of the discussion,
urban refugees in Jordan earn much more.
So in the capital city
Amman, they're earning
almost 300 US dollars
per household per month,
when we zoom in on just
the two governorates
that are around the
camps, Mafraq and Zarqa,
that's, it's still more than in the camps
but it's, it's much less
difference between the camps,
so about $110 relative to about $80
per household per month for camps.
- Hi, Thomas, I'm sorry to interrupt you,
I wonder if you could give us,
I know this isn't shown here
and maybe the sample's
not super large enough
to get into the details
but what do you know
about the distribution
of household income across these places?
- Yeah, so I'll talk a
little bit about that,
I mean, so 40% of
households in camps are...
40% of households outside of
camps are not earning anything
and 60% of households in camps
are not earning anything.
So it's...
- Sure.
- There's a large percentage
that have no earnings
from either wage or self-employment
and so it's, it's very kind of,
yeah, right skewed in that,
in that sense, for sure.
Does that answer your question?
- Yeah, and a little bit,
a little bit different
across places too, it sounds like.
- Yes, I mean the, the furthest right tail
is definitely in Amman
but that's, there's not
that many refugees earning
a substantial amount of money.
- Got it, okay, thanks.
- Great, so then I'm gonna add the red bar
of remittances and pensions
and any other income
that's coming in, that's
a very small proportion
of the reported income for refugees here
and then the assistance,
again as I said, it's
similar across locations
in terms of how refugees
report the value of this,
so it's the largest
proportion in terms of camps,
camp residents but a substantial amount
for off the refugees in the
other governorates around camps
and also with...
- Sorry, Thomas, the
type of aid they receive,
is it similar,
do they receive perhaps
primarily food in camps,
something else like
services outside of camps
or how similar it is in terms of...?
- I think, I think it's fairly similar,
we don't have, we don't have, we have data
on whether they receive food
and cash but not the amounts
and then a total amount
for the total value,
so I think there's probably
a little bit more cash
outside of camps than
inside of camps or yes,
but both refugees outside
of camps and inside of camps
are receiving food in-kind, food vouchers,
all the kind of same, same
general bundles of assistance.
- All right, thanks.
(Thomas whispering)
- So now when we look at the
rent that refugees are paying,
we, when you look at the
governorates around camps,
they're actually paying
the middle set of columns,
more outside of camps
in these governorates
than they're earning.
So with assistance on average,
they're, they still have
kind of net positives
for other expenses but they're
actually paying more in rent
than their total earnings.
In camps, they're obviously
not paying anything
and then in Amman, this, the
total rent is almost as much
as they're earning
but a little bit less, a
little bit larger difference
for residents in Amman.
So then the story I'm gonna be telling,
is one about this, this
net difference here.
So again, you kind of subtract
zero from the total income
for camps and then
subtract out the, the rent
for the governorates around camps
and you can see that this
is, in camps this is higher
for these residents by
not an enormous amount
but a, a noticeable amount
in these just raw data
and so then the next step
is going to be saying,
Well, what about kind of both observable
and unobservable differences
that we wanna think about
on all of these dimensions?
The last thing I'll just note here,
is that when we compare
these two Jordanians,
the red dot here
is the total household
income of Jordanians,
we also have in the survey, you
can see that they're earning
both in these two other
governorates around the camps
and in Amman, earning substantially more
but the average rent that they're
paying is almost identical
for Jordanians and refugees
in urban areas.
So this kind of net of
expenses is much different
for Jordanians than it is
for Syrians in this setting.
So now we wanna think
about whether, the goal
that we have in mind here
is to estimate how camp
residents would have done
outside camp, right?
Is this net kind of a real effect,
are these, what would the
wage effects, the wage penalty
of living in a camp be if refugees live,
if the camp residents
live outside of camps?
So for the economists,
I wanna think about this
as like the Treatment
on the Treated estimate.
So not necessarily if
you wanna match refugees
who were in camps to
the most similar people
outside of camps, to get
just that counterfactual
and not the kind of
average treatment effect.
And then we also wanna think about this
as the partial equilibrium.
So instead of camps closing completely,
we wanna think about this first exercise
as just one resident is
going to be leaving the camps
and so that, that marginal
effect, that partial effect
but the, but the camps still remain open
in terms of all the other
kind of price and wage effects
that that could have and I'll
come back to this at the end.
So the very simple classic
identifying assumption here
is that conditional on this
rich set of observables
that we have, the choice to
live in a camp is independent
of the potential outcomes
and specifically to the labor market
that I'm gonna be measuring to start with
and I will go through
the selection process
that I think makes that
potentially plausible
and then again, kind of the
second identification strategy
gives me more confidence
that this is in, in a reasonable
benchmark to go from here.
So I'm gonna have these
85 baseline covariates,
it's things about the
household demographics,
about their housing
characteristics in 2010
before displacement, 17 different assets,
their exposure to violence,
the amount of time
that they've been in Jordan,
obviously things like that
and then at the individual
level, again for a subset,
we have the 2010 outcomes
on employment status,
on occupations, on wages,
on their education levels,
all of these kinds of, of things
that feed into this,
this estimation strategy.
And so then the location choice
is one I'll be talking about
both in terms of estimating
this effect of living in a camp
but also I think it's just
interesting on its own
that there's this perception
that the vulnerable; the poor,
more women and children are
the ones who go to camps
and I'm gonna find some evidence for that
but not as kind of clear as I
originally, as I had expected.
So again, consistent with it being
kind of a more, more vulnerable
ex-ante who would have moved
and who would have stayed in camps,
I'm gonna find the camp
residents have a few,
had fewer rooms in 2010 in their house,
they had less likely
to have a water heater,
less likely to live in apartment,
less like they have a tiled floor,
so everything here to the
left of the red line, the zero
means that camp residents
were kind of less likely
to have these things.
And so you're gonna see
this very strong prediction
of the housing characteristics
based on whether refugees by 2016,
are living in or outside of camps.
And so I think that makes a lot of sense
when we think about kind of
the, the housing characteristics
and I'll go through that more
but then there also would
have been kind of other things
that I would have expected
around household size,
the number of dependents,
that if this was...
it could have fed into this story
and doesn't as much as
I would have expected.
Also refugees in camps, so
that could have suggested
this is just a straight
story of negative selection,
the people who would have
had lower potential earnings
in the urban labor markets,
are the ones who opt into camps
and so a lot of this
difference is explained
just by these kinds of
ex-ante characteristics
but there's other pieces
of evidence in the data
that suggests that
that's not the only thing
that's going on here.
So refugees just on average,
were more likely to have vehicles,
we're more likely to have televisions,
who ended up living in a camp by 2016.
They were equally likely to kind of say
that they meet their basic needs
and the two most predictive
elements in the data
of whether you live in a camp or not,
are just how long you've lived in Jordan,
so urban residents have lived in Jordan
for longer than camp residents
and whether you lived closer
to the border of Jordan
before displacement.
So as I said, it's gonna, I think a lot
of what's going on here is
this just willingness to live
in one of these caravans
that they were distributed
and it was kind of part of
the built up environment
in these camps.
And so here's a sense
of what these look like,
they're basically like these,
these shipping containers
that refugees were, were given.
And so they started out in these
canvas tents until mid 2013
and then moved to these, these caravans
and I think that your
just willingness to live
in these caravans, was what's
driving a lot of this sorting.
So I'm gonna have some evidence
that the more space per person,
kind of you were allocated
upon your arrival to camps,
the more likely you were to stay
and that's gonna be just one
of the main driving factors
much more than your kinda
potential labor market outcomes
or correlating with your
2010 labor market outcomes,
that's really explaining
a lot of the story.
So going along that, we look
at this, again, these random samples
of the males and females on
their labor market outcomes
and we don't see a significant difference
in terms of education, it's
almost exactly the same
in terms of whether they
were in school in 2010,
we actually see it's not
statistically significant
for males but it is for females,
that males and females were
more likely to be employed
of those who've moved and
who were in camps by 2016
and consistent with some more
kind of, on an individual level,
some kind of positive selection,
refugees males who had jobs
in 2010, camp residents
were more likely to have a higher ISCOs
for a kind of one to four level
of whether, what skill
level their job require.
And so overall, this
is not explaining a lot
of the variation in where
refugees are ending up by 2016
but it butts up against the story
that this is just, these are the people
who would have been, just attain less
in the labor market overall.
And so I think this is really a story
about kind of housing preferences
and what housing you were
kind of expecting and used to,
much more than it is necessarily
about your potential
labor market outcomes.
That's also supported
when we just ask refugees
why they were moving
and so out of the refugees
who located from camp
to urban areas, the
biggest one is insecurity
because at the beginning
of Za'atari being open,
there's no doubt that
there was a massive problem
with insecurity and those major problems
were eventually kind of
gotten under control by UNHCR.
So that's the number one reason
that the refugees reported leaving,
the second one is looking
for a bigger or better home.
So I think this is important
and kind of goes with the
other empirical data presented,
the, when we're thinking
about whether this is driven
by labor market outcomes,
eight people said
this was work-related
but that's much smaller
than for instance I was expecting.
We similarly, when we look
at people who've moved
from urban to camps, it's a
smaller number but the largest
besides insecurity in the
urban areas, the largest number
that people report is
that rent was too high
again, kind of consistent with housing
being a major factor for (murmurs).
So now I'm gonna move into,
I'm gonna take these estimates,
this kind of story of selection
and these baseline characteristics
and I'm going to put these into
a Generalized Random Forest,
which is an algorithm from
Susan Athey et al in 2018
that generates a propensity
score around the predictions
of who's more likely to live
in a camp versus urban area
within Jordan at the time of the survey.
And so this algorithm is
going to flexibly capture
different interactions and
you kinda have higher orders
of the potential
explanatory variables here
of who's locating in which area
and once you kind of tune this
and take into account all of
these different variables,
it's with 81% accuracy able to predict
who's, where refugees
are going to be living
at the time of, of the survey.
And so I think this, this
does a fairly good job
of capturing the, the selection story here
and the, again, the main
factors that fall out
are that the arrival month is
the most predictive element
of where refugees are going to live,
followed by their housing characteristics
and their origin,
origin governorates for
where they end up living.
Then I'm gonna take this propensity score
and I'm gonna use this to balance
across 2010 characteristics,
so I'm gonna use
the Imbens & Rubin method
to instead of matching kind
of one for one directly,
refugees in and out of
camps, I'm going to stratify
and create different blocks of refugees
that are mostly similar
within that propensity score.
And then I'm just gonna
follow the algorithm
that Imbens and Rubin have, have laid out
in order to create this,
this blocking estimate
that gives me this Treatment
on the Treated estimate
of how much the, to estimate this effect
of how refugees would
have done outside of camps
and then I'm gonna present the results
from Ordinary Least Squares
and from other methods
in order to just look at
the straight selection
with just a linear specification.
And whenever I do that, I'm gonna control
for the head of household's
age, age squared, the gender,
their 2010 education, the
months that they were displaced,
fixed effects for the origin governorate
and then the linearized propensity score
that I estimate from this
in order to capture just those
selection characteristics.
And then I'm gonna present
two different estimates,
so one is with, without
governorate fixed effects
and this is going to then
basically estimate the effect
of living in a camp,
relative to the average
of all potential destinations
outside of the camp
and this is specifically in this case,
gonna take into account Amman
where refugees could have gone out,
gone, ended up had they left the camp
and then I'm gonna present
another specification
that estimates within governorate,
so just comparing essentially refugees
who were living in Mafraq
with refugees who lived
in Camp Za'atari next door
and refugees who lived in Zarqa, relative
to
the camps, who lived, the
refugees who live in Azraq
and the Za'atari Governorate.
So now I'm gonna get onto the results
unless there are any questions.
- Yeah, Thomas, I did have
a couple of quick questions,
could you go maybe back two slides?
- Yep, this slide?
- Yeah, perfect, thanks.
One question is, how are
you thinking about origin
as being a predictor?
Is that, are you thinking maybe
they have existing networks
in Jordan or something like that?
- Yes, exactly.
So almost half of the refugees in Jordan
are from the Dara'a Governorate,
which is the Southern
most governorate in Syria
that borders Jordan
and so the further that
you came to Jordan,
the less likely you are to live in a camp
and I think those people
probably had other people
that they were, were looking
to meet in, in Jordan already
and things like that.
- Got it and then the other
thing I, that maybe put me off
if you like, could you just
talk me through how to think
about the combination of the
propensity score and the OLS?
Or like could you, I'm thinking
of kind of typical
propensity score measures,
you would just, you would
do some kind of matching
based on the propensity score
and then here you're throwing
it, the propensity score
into an OLS regression
with some other covariates
that maybe were already a
part of the propensity score,
how should I be interpreting
that or thinking about it?
- Yeah, exactly, great question.
So
the algorithm recommended
by Imbens and Rubin
is to create these blocks,
so basically I'm gonna
have like six blocks
that within each one of those blocks,
I'm going to then run the OLS
that controls for these
kind of main characteristics
that I chose ad hoc, in order
to, to net out those effects
and then that creates a treatment effect
within each one of these blocks
and then you weight blocks
by the the number within the blocks
and by the, those estimates.
And then I'm just gonna have to display
just OLS specification
with everybody as well.
So there's two different things,
one is kinda within the OLS
and within the stratification
and then another one is just OLS
with the linearized propensity score
and the other explanatory variates.
- Okay, thanks.
- Great.
So the first outcome
that I'm gonna look at,
is that camps reduce household earning
and this outcome is gonna
be a total of the wage
and self-employment income
that was 30 days prior to
the time of the survey.
And so I'm gonna look at this
in just the absolute measure
in terms of USD on the left here
and then take the inverse hyperbolic sign
in order to account for these many zeros.
Again, 60% of households
don't have any earnings
from this wage and self-employment
income and, in camps
and 40% don't have any
earnings in urban areas
and so it's important that
if we just took the log
we wouldn't be able to include
these households with zero.
And so this is gonna give me
these overall household level effects
and so you can see with, without
governorate fixed effects
are compared to everybody,
all the urban residents,
I'm gonna estimate an
effect, I think of $67 here,
that's statistically significant,
when I moved to just
estimating to refugees
within the nearest governorates,
it's still gonna be a negative
effect for camps on earnings
but it's actually not
statistically significant.
And I find basically the same thing,
when I transform the inverse of log Sin.
This is that same thing
in regression form,
so that's the, from these
blocks again, I've got
kind of six blocks here
that I put all together
that gives me this $67 effect
off of an urban mean of $192
and so that's the kind
of first specification,
it's very similar when I don't worry
about this blocking estimate
and just pull everything
into the same regression
and this is gonna give me $63
wage penalty for living in a
camp and then the Oster Delta
for whether the unobservables
could potentially overturn
these results is above one,
which means that we wouldn't,
would expect that selection
is doing on observables
it's doing a fairly good job here
and the unobservables
wouldn't overturn this result.
So these results are driven largely
by lower male employment,
45% male employment in urban regions
relative to 32% for camp residents
and so that's where the
majority of the earnings penalty
is coming from for living
in a camp in this setting.
I was also surprised to see
there's actually a positive
effect for females,
for female employment.
So it is, in this case,
there's 9% employment for women
in camps versus 2% outside of camps
and I think in most of
what's going on here,
86% of the employment for women in camps
is through non-profits
basically looking to have
kind of equitable access to these jobs
and so that's a substantial
and I think important story
but it's not enough to kinda compensate
for the overall household earnings.
So then I'm gonna move into
calculating this net income
per capita and that's
gonna take these earnings,
so from self-employment,
from, from wage employment
and I'm gonna add the other income,
I'm gonna add assistance,
then I'm gonna subtract out
a conservative estimate
of the minimum expenses
that refugees might have
faced outside of the camp.
And so in order to calculate that,
I'm gonna take the 10th percentile of rent
within the governorates
that refugees outside of camps would pay.
So I'm gonna standardize the
expenses in camps to zero
and then subtract out the minimum expenses
that refugees are paying in urban areas
but take a very conservative
estimate of that.
They're also paying more
outside of camps for school
and for health costs
and I'm not even going to
factor those into account,
again, to give kind of a
very conservative estimate
of how much is being saved
from living in a camp.
Another kind of outcome
we would think about
or to, in order to benchmark
the expense food prices
but the median food prices
reported inside and outside camps
are identical in this setting.
And then I'm gonna convert
this to per capita estimates
in order to standardize with
the cost estimates that I have.
So when I just look at the total income
per capita here first, I still
get this negative effect,
about $10 per person per
month of living in a camp
but when I subtract out these
net with minimum expenses,
this is when I get kind of
the overall positive effect
of net expenses of living in a camp
and because there's kind
of a different expense
subtracted out for different governorates,
I'm gonna get a similar
coefficient, a similar effect
whether you compare them to everybody
including those living in
Amman or to the refugees
who are living in the
most kind of similar areas
of about $11 per person per
month net for camp residents.
Some additional evidence that I have here
is that
in order to, so refugees inside of camps
are much less in debt than
refugees outside of camps
and the story that I
think explains this best
is that refugees outside of camps
are having to go into more debt
in order to afford their
larger housing costs.
So these estimates are very large,
about 80% of refugees
in the urban settings,
who expressed a debt
of at least 100 dinar,
which is $140 and that's
20 percentage points less
in the urban area, in for
refugees who are living in camps.
With, I'm also not seeing any difference
in access to credit
and so that, that wouldn't
explain this either,
I'm, then if you asked just
in this subjective measure
of whether refugees consider
their household to be poor
or not, it's actually lower
that fewer refugees consider
themselves poor in camps
than outside of campus, isn't
statistically significant
but I think also kind of illustrative
that the financial situation
for refugees outside of camps
may be much worse, 84% here
than I think we kind of have in mind
when we wanna think about
urban refugee situations.
So I should note also here
that there's fewer assets
for refugees who are in, in
camps in terms of TVs, radios
and appliances, I think this has changed,
this is increasing over time
and so converging in some sense
but it's not that, it's
an important difference
that's also should be
noted, when we're thinking
about kind of these
total, total effects here.
So then a major concern about
refugees over the long-run
and living in camps
is how these effects are going to evolve.
And so what I do for this,
again refugees on average
have only been in these
camps about 2 1/2 years
but I'm gonna look at those
refugees who were in the camps
when we asked about September, 2013
and I'm going to look at
their employment outcomes
at that point relative to their outcomes
when we surveyed them
in the spring of 2016.
And so if you kind of think
about the parallel trends
that if you assume that
they would have been
on parallel trends if
not for living on camps,
then you can interpret this
as kind of
the difference of camps.
And so you'll see here that
while the employment is lower
for males in camps,
they're on a similar trend,
increase over this time period,
wage growth is a little bit higher
for refugees outside of camps
but growing also for
refugees inside of camps.
And then I've also gone
back to the 2018 survey,
so two years later
and this employment
has basically converged
between refugees outside of
camps and inside of camps.
So 46% employment outside of camps
but up to 44% inside of camps
and so it seems like the refugees
are actually on even a faster
employment growth at least,
within camps by 2018.
When we look at women,
it's important to note
that they started off
higher, employment percentage
and so there might be some
kind of selection bias
going on here
but this is also a substantially
larger wage growth,
again, I think mostly
attributed to non-profits
but it also persists into 2018,
there's 8%, percentage points
versus three percentage points by 2018.
Just not enough really to estimate
kind of wage, wage effects
here and then the differences
but I think this, again, it
doesn't provide evidence,
much evidence that refugees
in camps are stagnating
much more than refugees outside of camps,
that is just an important
thing to kind of keep in mind
and to continue to survey these
populations and to monitor
as we think about the long-run aspects.
Then we wanna think about
amenities and services,
so I'm gonna find actually the
primary school aged children
in camps are more likely to
be in school by two, in 2016
and so it's not, it's not a lot
but here at very at much younger ages,
we see that they are more
likely to be in, in school
and this drops off for both
camp and urban refugees
as we get into secondary
schooling, unfortunately here
but not substantial evidence
that children in camp schools
are at least attending much less.
- Does school attendance differ,
sorry to interrupt, does school
attendance differ by gender?
- No, not that I, not that
I was picking up here.
- And do you have a good explanation
for why attendance for
five years old is so low
in urban areas?
- I don't have much of a sense,
I think that one guess could
be that urban households
were waiting a little bit to,
because there are some
school fees associated
in urban areas, whether
those are formal or informal
but they're just like
delaying a little bit,
would be one explanation
and also like efforts within the camp
in order to get more kind of
school, children in school.
- Maybe because there are
not enough preschools as well
or the age, the legal
age for entering school
is set around six probably
or something like that.
- Yeah, I don't have, I don't
have a great, great sense
but it at least doesn't suggest
that they're doing much worse
in camps than outside of camp.
- Sorry, Thomas, I have one
more question about the schools,
I just wanna compare them to Lebanon,
are they mixed shifts or one shift,
combining Jordanians and Syrians together
because this is an issue that
we're facing here in Lebanon.
- Yes, so just...
- Sorry if I, I didn't finish yet,
plus the curriculum actually,
that was actually an issue.
This is why the Syrian
curriculum in teaching,
hoping for the kids to return back home,
is different than the Lebanese one,
so there was also another issue,
I just, I'm just wondering
if this is the same case in Jordan
- Yes, so Jordan also
opened the two shifts
in high prevalence areas,
so I actually have another
program, another project
that demonstrates how this,
basically Jordanian students
were not very exposed to Syrian students
but the prevalence of
Syrians in these schools
was pretty low and Syrians were mostly
in this kind of second
shift of, of education.
So it's very similar in the
Jordanian context as well.
Thanks.
- Thank you.
- And so then public services,
people are less satisfied in camps
but overall people feel,
report feeling very safe,
safe or very safe, both
inside and outside camps.
And just one more point here,
is that women in camps list
a lot more regular contacts
than urban women, one thing I noticed
when I was kind of
doing part of the survey
was women who were in urban
areas were expressing loneliness
and isolation from not having
the kind of same networks
that, and being afraid to,
to leave and be able to find
kind of, build a community
like refugees in camps had
and that's also born out in the data.
- So just a quick clarifying
question, you mentioned earlier
that concerns about
safety were a major driver
of choosing living in a
camp versus urban areas
but then you find that
actually everyone feels safe
regardless of where they end up living.
- Yep...
- Is that correct?
- That's definitely a
function of at the beginning,
these camps were very insecure
and the government and UNHCR
has done a lot to, to
improve security over time.
So that's an evolution over time.
- Got it, thanks.
- Sorry, Thomas, can I interrupt..
Sorry, go ahead.
- No, go ahead, I'm
gonna, I was gonna move
to the next thing.
- Just, yeah, just regarding,
probably we're backpedaling
a little bit, regarding
the demographic studies
when you were mentioning
the employment for women
did you also consider that some women,
because this is the case I'm facing
when I'm doing my, when I
finished my infographic studies,
the results that came from
that, that most of them
who are employed are
usually either widowed
or their husband is jailed
or got lost during the war.
So I'm not sure if you
factored in this variable
to justify the employment
of women increasing.
- That's interesting, I
will, I'll look at that,
I would suspect that there's
some of that going on,
again, my main explanation here,
there's very little women
employment in urban areas at all
and so not really enough
to be able to tease out
whether it's a male or
female head of household
but within camps, I can
look at that a little bit,
we do have their household
demographics from 2010,
so let me get back to you on
that, again, most of the story
I think is really the opportunity
provided by nonprofits
in the camps but that,
still within that employment
might be the story that you have in mind.
- Okay, thank you.
- So again, kind of going to...
Oh, there a question...
- There's one question,
yeah, there is a question
there on the "Chat"
about the, if male-headed
households are more likely
to be in urban areas than female-headed.
- Female-headed households
are a little bit more likely
to be in, in camps than outside of camps
but not substantially.
It's not a major predictor
of who's going to locate in which area.
Thanks.
So we are talking about
kind of the evolution
over time here and this is
the, the Cantril Ladder.
So asking people to recall
that has all kinds of problems
but I think it's still useful exercise
where high here is, "My life
could not be any better"
and one here's, "My life
could not be any worse"
and so consistent with there being a...
the camps improving over time,
we see on these blue lines
here, these are people
who were in Za'atari in 2013,
the conflict started and
satisfaction goes way down,
many of these stayed in Syria
for the initial parts of the conflict
and then the camp is a
really rough place to be
at this time and we see
kind of steady improvement
to the point where at
the time of the survey,
that we see no differences
between Za'atari and urban areas,
we see a similar kind of
U-shaped trend here in Azraq
but Azraq is still, people report
substantially lower satisfaction in Azraq
and I think that's because it's
more isolated, it's hotter,
it's just worst place to be
and I'll talk about that at the end,
I don't see any differences
on the employment,
income effects that I've
talked about earlier
and so I pulled those together
but on the satisfaction,
differences most definitely emerged here.
When I moved to Kurdistan here,
there is a very, very different setting,
refugees had access to work,
they had freedom of movement
to leave the camps completely
and so I think this is just a better model
from especially like a
human rights perspective
and just a better model overall,
I see similar effects in
terms of the potential,
the camp wage penalties.
So substantial wage penalty
from living in a camp
that refugees earn much less
but when I subtract out
the minimum expenses
in the same way that I did for Jordan,
you see this positive effect
here, the blue for Jordan,
this is basically a zero in camps,
so this wage penalty is,
is basically netted out
by the rent that camp refugees save
in the Kurdistan region.
So now the last couple of slides here,
so cost-effectiveness.
so there's not many estimates
of the cost across locations,
I'm trying to pull the
two main ones that do this
in 2014 was the best I could find
but the nonprofits through the
Syrian Response Plan estimate
that it's about $60 per person
per month, more expensive
to serve refugees in camps
than it is outside of camps.
I'm gonna take this
estimate, then I'm gonna look
at this USAID study on the
fiscal effects from 2014
and this is gonna provide the estimates
from the government expenditures.
So how much the...
whatever is going through
the Jordanian government
in terms of education, health,
electricity, subsidies,
municipal services, food and gas subsidies
and this is net of the
Regional Response Plan
so the gross budget
support is going on here
and that's for the government,
it's $51 per person more expensive
to serve refugees outside of camps.
So overall that's a $9 difference
plus the $11 difference
that I messed with in here
again, it's a very rough
estimate of about $2.
Now we think about the
general equilibrium.
So think about the thought experiment
of that Jordan has never opened camps
and they host the same number of refugees.
So this would represent a 22% increase
in the urban refugee population,
that then we think about
the effects on refugees
and on the host communities.
So for refugees, potentially
there will be crowd out
of each other from housing and from jobs
and that would mean that
these current estimates
actually understate the camp surplus
that I'm estimating here
but for Jordanians, like I said earlier,
the main effects are not from income,
are not from public services
in terms of education
or from access to healthcare
that Syrians are crowding
and Jordanians are having
a negative effect on,
it's the cost of living.
And so that there's very
inelastic supply of housing
and so there's two different papers
that estimate large increases from Syrians
who locate close to Jordanians,
having a substantial negative effect
on the Jordanians in that area.
And so if we think about
again, refugee camps
is providing this additional housing
would alleviate some of that burden,
I think that's a very
important kind of a factor
to build in here when we're
thinking about the overall net
of camps and what camps that could be.
The other thing I'll say
quickly is that if camps close,
you can think about the aid budget
potentially being affected.
So one Jordanian official said me
that the, one of the
arguments for opening a camp,
was simply because they
learned their lesson
with Palestinians
that the aid money they
suspected was much less
because they allowed people to assimilate
and so with Syrians, they
wanted to keep them visible
in order to keep the aid money flowing
and I'm actually going
to be looking at this
in another project forthcoming.
So my final slide here
is just kind of what, what are
we, what should we take away
from this estimates, from,
from this discussion?
And so I think about this
as Za'atari and Kurdistan,
as being kind of the lower
bounds of what camps,
and I put that in quotation marks,
as like suburbs or enclaves could be
for a humanitarian response.
So thinking about making
these areas attractive
for refugees, it could be a win-win
but that I think this, this
environment shows the design
and the content are key.
So that, it's possible that
returns to in-kind shelter
or even higher than the cash equivalent,
when we kind of factor
everything in here overall,
again, owing to the fact
that this housing supply,
is so inelastic in the short-run
and builders are gonna find it risky
to invest in this population
that they don't know exactly
how long they're going to be staying,
refugees want to go home,
host communities want them to go home
and so the housing market
might not immediately respond
with like standard housing
in order to house a refugee population
and that shelter here is just
gonna to be a key constraint
for both refugees and for hosts.
But providing that shelter
does not have to imply
the other restrictions
that we often associate with camps.
These camps don't need to
be isolated in the same ways
that we see in, in the Jordanian context
and in other contexts, you
don't need to impose limits
on movement or restrictions
on, on permanent building,
those are likely lose-lose situations.
So we see from the examples
in Azraq relative to Za'atari
that fewer refugees are going
to stay in more isolated,
in worse areas, they're gonna
be higher costs for nonprofits
to engage in the water
trucking and waste management
in more remote areas.
And so these are just lose-lose,
whereas if we could
incentivize camp residents
or suburban residents,
we wanna call it that,
to minimize kind of citizen crowd out
and reduce expenditures on refugees,
I think there's a better
model in here somewhere
than just kind of pretending
that refugees in urban areas
are going to be doing better just overall.
And so we also wanna think
about the kind of
counterfactual labor market
and housing markets that matter here
that those are going to be,
they're weak in this context,
in the Jordanian context,
whereas we think about this in Europe,
that might be totally different
and we wanna kind of
reevaluate this overall
but it's just important
to kinda keep in mind
we're thinking about generalizability
and then as well as kind of
following the long-run outcomes
but totally acknowledged
that these kind of outcomes
are also are very uncertain
and just kind of call
for more research in this area
to keep this discussion open
around kind of what, what
arrangements could be better
for both kind of host
communities and refugees.
So I will leave it there.
Thank you so much for, for
having me and for the questions
and I'm happy to stick around with anyone
that wants to, to chat more.
So thanks again.